cohol Dennehy joins us from Dublin k'hal
how are you i am good then how are you
I'm spectacular set the scene of so this
is a 4 x 400-meter race and so how big
event was this so this was in the irish
university's track and field
championships last saturday afternoon in
century stadium and there must have been
no more than 100 people in the stadium
but it went a bit crazy for it it was a
very quiet day not a big atmosphere and
then suddenly with the people who were
there went absolutely crazy and myself
my friend going in building who were
doing commentary for the live stream
online YouTube stream and we basically
as you can tell lost one of ourselves
completely lost their minds lost our
voices lost our composure lost their
professionalism and because the athlete
like as you can see it was what it was
one in four minutes which isn't that
fast for a four by four relay for them
the athlete who actually won the race
came from about 80 yards back on the
final leg and again it wasn't a
brilliant legs at least out front
obviously what this is the international
class at least was running for the core
team and I mean to see her come we add
as you could tell we got a completely
wrong we'd written her off we'd even
written off the second in fair that a
product the beauty of sports young
picked ability of support came through
in the end all right the call is
dramatic i mean you're selling that like
it's the olympics which I appreciate
that you're saying there's a hundred
people there it's a woman's you know
University Games and you guys are
selling it like the Olympics so I do
appreciate that I am curious about
depths from the depths of hell have you
ever used that in a sporting event
before I have not and I guess it shows
that I'm a not a full-time broadcaster
because I think people can hit a
questionable statement to come out with
in the middle of a race but uh no I'm by
trade I guess I'm a writer I'm a
journalist free than track and field
journalist or I write for a number of
publications newspapers and self and
occasionally we get drafted in to do
these kind of commentary gigs live
streams and in general it's just people
actually asked me did you have that
written down did you see it to learn
yeah I have no idea where I even poor
best turn of phrase from it made no
sense I think maybe it was with the
rights Inglis charging from nowhere no
were you usually get that made me think
of hell most yeah it made no sense and
uh yeah it seems to work out people seem
to love it will you use from the depths
of hell again now I think you know these
things are best retires after women Wow
good I'll just leave it there breaking
news cohol Danny hey confirms that he
will never use the expression from the
depths of hell that's sort of the
women's Irish games version of Al
Michaels saying do you believe in
miracles I think I think so yeah we have
our own ones and Ireland decided upon in
terms of famous sporting phrases there
was one of the Irish are in the world
cup in 1990 and a guy approached in the
quarter finals are the second round to
take a penalty and the commentator said
a nation holds its breath that was the
indelible one that found in Irish
sporting history no doubt there's tons
of zoo in America as well for ya i think
i think we'll leave it there i think
were from the depths of hell it worked
at once or not i think you can get too
much of a good thing so i think we leave
it there how surprised are you with the
reaction to this I mean it's been it's
been absolutely crazy and to see it
going from even on national Irish
newspapers and then we'd a friend in New
Zealand who said he saw it on the
biggest news station there is in New
Zealand last night on TV heard our voice
voices screeching the house of TV like
12 year old prepubescent children or
some but yeah it's been loyal de menthe
to see it all
big networks in America picking up now
it's just domestically wild and I think
it's been for the sport of track and
field we just had a really bad couple
years and as we all know has had all
these drug scandals and things we've
seen the bad side of the sports be able
to get something of this like there that
portrays in the most pure way the
essence of like fundamental noble
competition i think is great for the
sport and I couldn't be happier that it
has taken off and again the commentators
aren't the stars of the show of yet
lives here and especially feel he and
all the other athletes who are working
hard and doing so the right way and
doing so without anybody really
appreciating their efforts there the
starless there's the show before you
retire from the depths of hell could you
just maybe do a liner for us to say from
the depths of hell this is the Dan
Patrick show of course okay I like what
I shoot all right I'm going to count you
two here in three two one from the
deaths of her at the Dan Patrick show
signing off and piling through to
victory got to fight then well done you
could have had it a little higher
pitched voice like it was right at the
end of the race there yeah well I didn't
have four minutes to work of a live
commentary I think I said oh sound too
much like a girl back then hey it's
great to have you thanks for having a
sense of humor and if we ever get to
Dublin beers are on me thank you Dan if
I ever get over there beers are on me oh
all right we'll take you have you been
to the state I have a word with in New
York for four months and then I've been
all over basically west coast East Coast
all right you get to New York effective
you get to New York and the beers will
be on us excellent take care dad thanks
for having that's cohol Dennehy
legendary irish sportscaster the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience